o futuro de todos é meu nome ao da
matriz ou a cientista
como cientista normalmente só falo sobre
aquilo que acha que conhece mas hoje eu
aceitei o desafio vos falar sobre algo
que não tenho bem a certeza sei o que
que o conhecimento é pura terceira final
que é o conhecimento e crescimento é
nada mais do que o ato ou efeito de
conhecer é ter uma idéia o ano são de
alguma coisa eu saber é e instrução que
é informação muitas vezes é conhecimento
com fundos também com estas duas outras
funções que é informação e essa
sabedoria e é isso olhar nos vai
preocupar demais com coisas quer dizer
na verdade a informação não passa de um
conjunto organizado de dados que não sei
se é bem a mesma coisa do que ter
conhecimento é constituir uma mensagem
sobre determinado fenômeno evento é e
funciona com o uso racional dessa
informação é base desse mesmo
crescimento outro lado sabedoria é
implica um conhecimento extenso e
profundo de várias coisas ou de um de um
tópico em particular é é a capacidade de
destruir abordada através das
experiências que está na base assim era
que consigamos essa teoria é o um dos
primeiros nomes que está no título minha
apresentação thomas l
alguns não conhecem mas foi pra mim
nobel da literatura em 1948 e tem amo
este é este poema ganhamos assim é que
eu acho muito voadora em relação à idéia
de extinguir estas três coisas de
informação conhecimento e sabedoria é eu
não vou eu não vou reclamar o poema
estava
é de assentar nestas três últimas frases
que vocês podem ler é o ex life of lost
e nem vem
os dois dão a voz e nord ouest dólar de
touch of information isto estas esta
forma de olhar para o problema é foi
também explorada é mais recentemente por
frank zappa que o colocou no fundo este
problema é de uma forma musical e se
tiverem a gentileza de passar é o som
deste do excerto do desta música e solta
o favorito é two foi um músico
compositor bastante polêmico que aborda
a questão da informação e conhecimento
o dólar
o movimento como um propósito music de
pesca mas acho que toca no ponto
fundamental foi o céu não é crescimento
crescimento não é sabedoria ea sabedoria
não é necessariamente verdade é e isto é
uma uma representação mais simplista é e
mais concretas quiserem aqui o que é o
crescimento que segundo platão
representa nada mais do que uma crença
brasileira e justificada e eu coloque
isso muito uma forma muito simples
cidade para este esquema que está
entregue à nossa frente é azul temos as
crenças que no fundo é só as crianças
que não foram mostrados são falsas
não não há nenhuma verdade nestas nestas
crianças que nós acreditamos sem
qualquer fundamento científico é
vermelho temos as verdades que são
desconhecidas
a questão temos as crenças verdadeiras
mas ainda não aprovadas e aquilo que eu
considero o crescimento são as crenças
bordadeiras e demonstrará significamente
que ocupa este aquele círculo amarelo
que engloba no fundo esta é a crença
brasileira justificada
mas afinal o que é ser cientista e qual
é o papel do cientista nesta aventura do
conhecimento é eu trago aqui 11 uma
mensagem muito especial
alguém que pra mim representou e
representa apesar de já ter conhecido
alguém que o time como exemplo opcional
de ser da silva pra mim representava é
enfim o que é verdadeiramente ser
cientistas sobre eu estava no bolso
falar um bocadinho desta frase que acho
que inscreve como ninguém o que é ser
vista na verdade está em inglês mas
pessoa a gente compreenderá no estande
do nosso câmbio médica deixando o lar de
biutiful e pilar 2007 para os céus
houve uma escala de cinco
houve um design down dúvida que tal que
bellucci ou crie ter sempre e isso
estava de sublinhar só os humanos são
capazes de ser criativos
este é o ponto fundamental que gostava
de ficar ao longo desta desta pequena
intervenção dos cientistas é bem mais
piá criem de forma ilegítima importância
desse kits de que foi em the observer
animax repetindo em 2000 sucedendo
lógica ao site bwin.com participate in
the city of which existe é um texto é do
outro grande serviço à transferência
roberts alemã há uns anos atrás comecei
a pensar neste problema todo do que
conhecimento informação e sabedoria
aplicado ao a área que me interessa
estudar e eu estudo o processo chamado
de mitó zico que não é mais do que o
processo de revisão do núcleo que está
na base sempre uma célula de vivo o
grande dilema que o investigador
o cientista encontra quando estuda alvo
é focar seu não é bettcher nuno
problemas com seu todo os pilares do
problema ou concentrar se em desvendar
os detalhes mais em filmes simplesmente
porque é possível que está aqui
representado estamos ao ativista
conseguem ver os cromossomas
organizar-se durante durante a divisão
ea partir de um determinado momento as
cópias dos cromossomas são distribuídos
por duas filhas conselhos nem eticamente
iguais
é um processo extremamente complexo do
qual sabemos ainda muito pouco viu o
olhar para esse processo usando é mais
recentes ferramentas com algumas
pequenas fotos de detalhes que
conseguimos ver isto chegamos é o estado
da arte tudo aquilo que conseguimos
perceber sobre este processo podem ver
que tem cromossomas que está
existem estes filamentos do
citoesqueleto que está havendo confirmar
esta é uma queria é que vai ser
responsável positivo estamos promoção
mas temos que começar a ouvir isso é o
que nós temos hoje é que nós possamos
ver hoje mas não é o que é surpreendente
é que há mais de cem anos atrás quando
este processo foi descrito pela primeira
vez
já outra fleming que conseguia ver quase
com o mesmo time usando microscópios
muito rudimentares que não se assemelham
se quer aquilo que nós conhecemos hoje
para usar hoje em dia
olhar para esse processo com um detalhe
muito e 20 do que o que nós
definitivamente conseguimos aprender
sobre este processo é em relação aquilo
que sabia quando foi escrito a primeira
vez é é o grande desafio é a minha
grande dúvida é se efetivamente temos
muito mais do que simples descoberta do
seu processo
normalmente as pessoas orienta o aluno
de doutoramento o evento outros
cientistas mais mas jovens normalmente
muitas vezes vem de empate em uma grande
equipe fez um grande primeiro tempo
melhorando a observação é e tem uma
coisa que está em causa é muito boa é
que estou muito excitado com esta
descoberta é uma das poucas coisas que
eu digo é a vai vai ver ao livro do
daniel média se eu já não descobriu isso
é o daniel meza foi um cientista um
filósofo dada a mitose quiserem que eu
tenho como a grande diferença é que
enfim decidiu o trabalho em 1961
escrever um livro com mais de 300
páginas sobre este processo que é mitose
tenham abordado em 300 páginas e deve
ter falado senão de tudo ou quase tudo é
esse alguém efetivamente pensar que
trata de um conceito novo sobre o
processo é e documentos sempre os mesmos
vamos ver vamos ver um livro do médico
que o parlamento já falou sobre isso
quando de fato não aconteceu então eu
acredito que temos algo novo é tão
curioso é que estas páginas que escreveu
é eram expostas e não existem mostrar
este prefácio eram expostas e parte do
bumbum dois de uma série muito maior e
que eu vou fazer parte de um vôo
desejamos assim quase em exclusivo por
que é complementado com o editor é o
senhor cônsul média é de kohl uma uma
magnum opus é ao tema e eu não queria
movimento deixar parte tudo o que eu
tenho pra dizer e que deixou em lugar
vendo assim para gerações futuras
é tudo questão aqui é o que efetivamente
conhecimento é isso representa uma
cascata de sinalização e tem muitas
dúvidas se efetivamente o facto de
sabermos esta complexidade toda que está
por trás dessas ligações se efetivamente
conhecimento
se olharmos para a rede de interações
genéticas foi compartilhado pode ser
ainda maior
conseguimos trazer hoje em dia o detalhe
as coisas mais pequenas domingo mais
pequeno detalhe mas não sei se temos o
conhecimento verdadeiro sob os
princípios básicos pilares que tem por
base um determinado processo com o nome
que hoje em dia é enfim a tentação de
pensar ok
já temos a informação toda a nossa
disposição mostrar que temos
efetivamente o conhecimento que tenho
pra mim é uma máxima é que acho que em
que achei inspiração nesta nesta frase
de um outro prémio nobel alberto santos
e hoje que o nightwish wars de normas e
fuck him aneel e monte mor site em nota
katz que fez e por esta mensagem é é a
forma como o oriente
a nossa investigação é é sempre pensando
da bp muito mais orientada para a bp ter
para o que efetivamente um salto
relevante no crescimento é em detrimento
de
é procura do mais ínfimo detalhe é é
afinal a função do cientista é
descoberta que nada mais do que o ato
irregular daquilo que não era conhecido
voltando ao nosso esquema do portão é o
que estava em manutenção
é é que efetivamente é naquela zona que
estava mal ele que é muito maior do que
o tesouro está a manuel que estão os
grandes desafios que estão por causa do
que chamou de bordados que ainda são
desconhecidas
eu tenho muitas dúvidas se é o sistema
que estamos é é montar a construir hoje
em dia o nosso sistema de educação foram
conquistados em educar as gerações
futuras se exploram se os treinos
efetivamente eles dão as capacidades
para estudarem estes grandes desafios
destas verdades desconhecidas tem muitas
dúvidas que o sistema de ensino por
exemplo muito é focado na competição na
insistência numa restos quiserem estudar
para o objetivo do teste estudar pra
nota os quistos leva a algum lado é e
tem pena que não seja um sistema que
promova muito mais criatividade e é toda
parte funciona com a criação do mato que
é muito muito cedo tem tudo a ver com o
ranking mesmo assim para que servem os
rankings das escolas e qualquer miúdo
tem filhos pequenos e preocupantes o
imea
o fato é dever e exames nacionais do
quarto ano e do 6º ano do ensino
fundamental pra nada grave para os
rankings das escolas que poderá servir
também para definir tensão depois o
projeto vários produtos nossos filhos
vão é orientados para uma outra
instituição onde é muito difícil entrar
é para isso que servem os recenseamentos
os rankings mas tem muitas dúvidas que
esta forma este é
promove efetivamente possível promover o
avanço do conhecimento ea mensagem que
buscavam estava deixar é que posso dizer
uma coisa que acredito fielmente o que é
melhor forma de avançar no conhecimento
é precisamente de prender nos deu é que
essa era a mensagem realmente gostava de
vos deixar o treino de forma frontera
frank zappa como a citação artes martins
ambiental nascem excelente foi mais ou
menos o que tenho que fazer hoje
obrigado por aqui